دراسه اجرتها شركه رابطها للتوظيف تقيم
فيها مستويات السعاده لاكثر من 12 الف
موظف خالصات الى امر بديهي الموظفون
الاكثر سعاده لديهم انتاجيه اعلى من غيرهم
الاستطلاع وجد ان الموظفين الذين لديهم
روابط وعلاقات جيده مع زملائهم في العمل
هم اكثر سعاده في وظائفهم بمقدار مرتين
ونصفا غيرهم من مسببات السعاده ايضا هو
شعور موظفين بالاستقلاليه والقدره على
اتخاذ بعض القرارات فيما يخصهم واداره
الوقت بمرونه وبحسب النتائج الموظفين
يفخرون بشركاتهم هم اكثر عرضه بثلاث مرات
للسعاده في العمل الدعم الايجابي والشعور
بالتقدير هو ثاني اكبر دافع لسعاده
الموظفين والتقدير يمكن ان يكون زياده في
الراتب او ترقيه او حتى رساله شكر قصيره
عبر البريد الالكتروني اما المحرك الاقوى
للسعاده فهو الشعور بالانجاز حيث يحتاج
الموظفين لشعور بان لديهم بصمه وتاثير على
الشركه